i'm gonna assume that uh it was
relatively business as usual
until uh the beginning of this year call
it sometime between january and march
uh and then all hell broke lose
basically in markets right and
everything from
uh kind of credit markets seizing up to
public equities
dropping and then exploding up in value
you saw commodities kind of all over the
place
um maybe talk a little bit just in with
the hindsight benefit now
of like where we sit today in uh
september of 2020
what's transpired from your position
up till now and then we could talk about
kind of moving forward but these are
some of the craziest markets that many
people have kind of
navigated and so kind of how have you
navigated those markets and kind of
what's changed from an asset allocation
standpoint for the clients that you guys
serve
so there's so much in that uh question
we could spend the entire time together
talking about that one let me start and
then you guide me
where you want me to go from there so in
thinking about
kind of into the end of 2019 and rolling
the calendar forward to 2020
we were actually feeling pretty good uh
despite how far the market had moved in
the back half of last year we were
feeling pretty good about positioning
we were starting to see some green
shoots in terms of a cyclical
acceleration
after a really kind of slow and tough if
not choppy slog over the course of 2019
and
i'll just throw this out for fun like
every year i try to assign
um a musical reference or a song of the
year
for the coming year and so this is going
to sound insane now looking back on it
but it's there's still
some truth to it the song we picked for
this year
um was the grateful dead truckin
and so the idea really was that given
all of what has gone on the long strange
trip that was the prior business cycle
investors really shouldn't get tripped
up um by some of the challenges that
were in front of us that we thought this
like the cycle still had legs and
it could keep going and so we did start
to see in january and february
pre-covered
that meaningful acceleration start to
take hold so we were feeling pretty good
about positioning and didn't make a ton
of changes
early in the year we did over the last
like 18 months like leading up to that
start to make some changes at the margin
because we felt like the cycle was
getting pretty long in the tooth
and we thought the volatility was going
to continue to pick up
were there a lot of headline risks macro
challenges around trade policy and that
sort of thing and so
to try and get clients still comfortable
with being fully invested
not overweight but comfortably fully
invested
according to their investment policy
statements and their strategic asset
allocation
we started to incorporate some asset
classes that had a little bit more
ballast
in them so as a good example we
incorporated global infrastructure
and that's a nice way to kind of
straddle the u.s and international
markets
stay in equities but dial back some of
the volatility exposure and so that was
kind of a key
story for 2019 even though the market
finally got its back together towards
the end of the year
of course covet hit that was not in our
crystal ball
sadly it was not in our 2020 outlook
by any means and so the world shifted
pretty dramatically the the good news or
bad news about it is
i think there are only about three days
in the midst of the record-breaking
downdraft
and then rally that anybody really had a
shot
at repositioning portfolios in a
significant way and so believe it or not
we stayed fully invested and rode
right through it um even though
volatility as measured by the vix
hit you know 80 plus like all-time
records and so our view on it was really
one that the markets over time have
wrestled with pandemics this is not a
new phenomenon
you know dealing with pandemics though
the magnitude of this one has obviously
been
really significant what was new is that
we proactively or
maybe reactively depending on how you
want to look at it shut down the global
economy
those two things were never synced up
before and so that was really
the key difference this wasn't um an
asset bubble bursting
or the kind of a typical or usual end to
a cycle
we shut this thing down and so
um in our view we didn't think that
there was a need to really pull the
record and de-risk
you know we've seen these things sadly
play out before you know the financial
crisis
is a good training ground for how big
markets can whipsaw around events like
this and so we felt given the strength
coming into 2020 the fact that this was
artificially induced that is we shut
down the global economy in response to
it
that it would be kind of a bridging the
gap shorter term
type of event and that you know maybe
things wouldn't normalize overnight but
that we would start to get
back to a recovery and relatively
shorter and so we felt
good about kind of staying the course of
course what has changed
since then is uh it wasn't just a few
short weeks you know it's hard to
believe that we're still
all very much kind of working remotely
and
i think something like half of gdp tied
to states today is still
in some form of pausing um or
readjusting their reopening plan so
we're definitely not
back to normal and i would say we're
definitely not that
but some lessons that we have learned
really so far
in the short period of time is that
there's a real distinction between the
haves and have-nots
wall street versus main street so we
we've started to see
an even bigger way than pre-covid
this really bifurcated market and
economic environment
start to assert itself here and you can
see it in
the day-to-day movement in the public
equity markets depending on what the
news flow
is suggesting on any given day it's the
stay-at-home trade you know everything
you need when you're hunkered down
or it's the go outside trade and it's
just this churning that continues to go
on but net net we think a really
significant
perhaps structural difference as a
function of what has gone on
since cove began is really that the
bigger likely to get bigger
and that the growthy are likely to get
growthier
and so what does that mean it means that
you know regardless of how long
this environment persists we think that
the bigger
names the mega cap tech in particular so
the queues which have garnered a ton
of headlines lately are really likely to
use this
environment to their advantage you can
already see it
in the companies that have fortress-like
balance sheets
that are paying dividends that have the
potential to grow their dividends
you can see it in the m a market um
there's leverage that's occurring here
for those business models that have been
able to kind of
manage fairly swimmingly technical terms
swimmingly through this
environment and yet the value side of
the equation
continues to struggle in a meaningful
way and so our view
over the course of the summer shifted to
be wait a minute this is not just a very
short-term
phenomenon we think there's something to
this and so we did tactically shift
away from small and mid-cap value
in domestic markets specifically because
of that and when we think about
small and mid value we're really looking
at exposures that span
the energy sector the financial sector
reits and even parts of consumer
discretionary and
we can talk about all the kind of thesis
and rationale behind that but even where
we sit today
even how far the market has rallied it's
really hard to point to a significant
positive catalyst
to really get any of those sectors and
especially the ones that are sitting in
the smaller
cap part of the spectrum going again we
think that all the stimulus that has
come into the system has definitely
saved the day
chair powell uh with a superhero cape on
absolutely changed the game
critical um but it also has
mass at least on the fiscal side it is
also mass a lot of the underlying
stresses
um that are only now starting to kind of
show up in the system and so
we've seen a few bankruptcies we've seen
some defaults but we really haven't seen
a meaningful default cycle
start up yet i think the longer this
goes on
and the longer we are not able to get
some form of fiscal stimulus going
the tougher slog it's going to be so we
may need to do more there
from a positioning standpoint but uh
believe it or not we are very
comfortable with our exposure
in the nasdaq 100 right now it's not let
me just clarify that is not our only
exposure
but making that tactical shift there
even where valuations are sitting and
even how far
that part of the market has rallied we
think there's a lot of opportunity left
there